les états unis épaulé par le danemark
pour espionner des figures politiques
européennes
la haine est ce l agence de
renseignements américains auraient pour
cela utiliser des systèmes d'écouté
câbles sous marins de télécommunications
des danois avec leur accord les faits se
sont déroulés entre 2012 et 2014 où
barack obama ils ont été révélés par une
enquête conjointe de la télévision
publique danoise dr et de plusieurs
médias internationaux dont le quotidien
français le monde
les journalistes danois ont évoqué un
rapport interne des services de
renseignement du pays
opération dunham heures les américains
avaient accès au fameux câble sous marin
en vertu d'un partenariat passé avec les
services de renseignement militaires
danois f16 été visés par ces écoutes
en premier lieu la chancelière allemande
angela merkel pour elle il s'agit de la
saison 2 puisque un premier scandale
d'espionnage la concernant avait éclaté
en 2013
autres personnalités ciblées en
allemagne le ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères qui officie à
l'époque frank walter steinmeier ainsi
que le chef de l'opposition peer
steinbrück qui a vivement réagi il est
grotesque que des services de
renseignements amy intercepte et
espionne effectivement les principaux
représentants d'autres pays
politiquement je considère que c'est un
scandale d'autres responsables
politiques ont été écoutés à leur insu
en suède en norvège et en france sans
que les noms est pour le moment était
dévoilée et pour remplir leur fiche
les américains avaient accès aux textos
aux appels ainsi qu'à toutes leurs
activités sur internet y compris les
messageries et les recherches
la ministre danoise de la défense trine
bramsen à son poste depuis juin 2019
n'aurait eu connaissance de ces faits
que depuis moins d'un an
elle a estimé que l'espionnage
systématique par des alliés est
inacceptable cet incident permet de
comprendre la mesure de l'espionnage à
grande échelle opéré par la haine et
c'est durant l'ère obama
les médias ont déjà révélé en novembre
2020 que la collaboration secret dano
américaines avaient visé des activités
industrielles et qu'ils ont même
poursuivi malgré les révélations de la
sphère snowden en 2013 et angela merkel
avaient d
fait les frais de l'espionnage américain
avertit d' écoutes menées par la haine
essaimé depuis berlin
elle avait demandé des comptes à barack
obama il avait botté en touche et fait
savoir qu'il n'y aurait pas d' écoute de
la chancelière à l'avenir selon le
quotidien allemand bild am sonntag le
président américain était au courant dès
2010 de telles opérations secrètes
n'oublions pas en france le scandale
lorsque laurent fabius avait demandé que
la station des côtes de la haine et
s'est posé sur le toit de l'ambassade
américaine à paris soit retirée le
lanceur d'alerté douar snowden était le
premier à dénoncer un réseau de
surveillance mondiale généralisée par la
haine et c il a réagi à ce nouveau
scandale
ironie de l'histoire il faudra désormais
demander des comptes à l'homme de la
situation qui a été le vice-président de
barack obama joe biden
by dane est bien préparé pour répondre à
cela lors de sa prochaine visite en
europe
car bien sûr il a été profondément
impliqué dans ce scandale la première
fois une divulgation publique totale
devrait être exigé non seulement de la
part du danemark mais également de son
partenaire principal quid du faut allier
le danemark le gouvernement danois a
déjà limogé le chef du renseignement
militaire en août 2020 ainsi que de
hauts responsables pour une autre
affaire l'europe semble condamnée à
laver son linge sale en famille et
blanchir ses membres